[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamais on a approché de si
près les
étoiles qu'en bâtissant un
jour la première
cathédrale
[Musique]
alléluia
Jean le tailleur de pierre est venu à
pied de son
Limousin
et du
Balong le charpentier et ses deux
cousins tris hiers en
terre pour les
fondations seront nécessaires mais les
murs tient
trop jamais on a approché d'I près les
étoiles
jamais quen bâtissant un jour la
première
cathédrale
alléluia
alléluia c'est de l'île de
que viennent les ches et les
peupliers et les maçons assemble les
boutres les voûes sur les grands
piliers pose tes
lumière mettre
vitrié et que le soleil soiton
prisonnier jamais on a approché d'aussi
près les
[Musique]
étoiles qu'on battissant un jour la
première
cathédrale
alléluia
alléluia j'enlève la tête où les
architectes lancent les
clochers et de la basse l'île les
truants les filles conttent leur
péchés en cet an de
grâce l'an
[Musique]
1300 lui qui nous regarde il sera
content
jamais on a approché d'aussi près des
étoiles
quand bâtissant un jour sa première
cathédrale
alléluia
alléluia la croche de l'évêque frappe
par de fois la porte au Glou
d'or et l'on chante au par les pieds on
suit les bourgeois
d'abord à genou la
ville c'est ici ton
cœur la foi te délire en une
[Musique]
clameur jamais on approchait d' aussi
près des
étoiles
jamais quen bâtissant un jour la
première
cathédrale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alléluia